le classement des artistes préférés on
va le revoir ici qui est sorti cette
semaine à deux choses qui sont
hallucinantes évidemment téléphone
francis cabrel eddy mitchell des gens
qui ont beaucoup de talent mais qui sont
là depuis des années il ya que deux
petits nouveaux s'est maître gims et
stromae et puis une seule ci est encore
céline dion que gamin un certain âge
encore qu'est ce qu'ils vont en
aménageant par là c'est pas une gamine
qu'est ce qu'il faut penser d'étals des
chimène badi ddd d'eux mêmes tout les
artistes qui arrivent aujourd'hui où
sont-elles pourquoi ce classement
magali pensent que le problème c'est les
gens à qui pose la question ils doivent
déposer sa dans les maisons de retraite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mami chan mais non c'est ma mission
c'était amusant mais pour des raisons
techniques on n'a pas plus âgés c'était
des gens les gens que tu cites au moins
deux tubes que cela répond désignons des
villes est vu d'un côté les tubes de
l'autre dans l'écrasante majorité en
dehors de stromae maître gims finalement
les autres ont chacun au moins trente ou
quarante tubes c'est tout qui fasse des
choses ou pas goldman il a pas fait
d'album depuis 2001 se rebellent ça fait
cinq ans ces accessoires et je pense que
si on avait ouvert le sondage demandant
aux gens leur chanteur préféré
même les chanteurs morts on a eu vingt
chanteurs morts en tête ouais parce
qu'ils ont plus de tubes c'est toujours
jean mais rien n'est pas qu'une question
tube c'est aussi qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya
plus vraiment de stars de grandes stars
qui font rêver les gens je vois nous
serons mieux tu dira la même chose ou et
sébastien aussi on se galère à mettre
des gens en souffrent tueur parce qu'il
n'y a plus personne n'a vraiment jamais